[Music]
lieutenant commander james reese
can you outline the details of your
mission
this was a targeted attack
my timeline is a little fuzzy but they
knew we were coming
[Music]
headaches
paranoia memory confusion
[Music]
still think i'm losing my mind
it's david versus goliath which one is
reef david or goliath
i'm still working that out
investigations are still ongoing into
the failures operation odin sword
missions resulted in the death of 12
navy seals
lieutenant commander james reese can you
outline the details of your mission
they knew we were coming going the audio
logs you went dark on comms roughly four
mics in
why
that's not how it went down
you okay
yeah i'm fine
headaches paranoia
memory confusion
we're gonna get through this okay
don't tell me what happened somebody fed
us bad intellect it's a setup
if i'm right we need to act on this
i need names if there's connection to
you and your men
i'll find it
answers
or blood
blood
where's james reese is it true your
fugitive is a navy seal there's a bunch
of people tracking you right now so just
lay low
i have 12 men flying home with caskets
right now what
this is personal
oh you wanted it on the fray now
you're in the battlefield
there's evil in this world the likes of
which you can't possibly imagine
james
take lucy get her out of the house now
i'm not gonna tell you again
stay off my list
you